it's seven o'clock this is sky news
breakfast our top stories this morning
a fresh blow to boris johnson's
leadership his brexit minister quits
over new covert restrictions as omicron
sweeps the country the lack of
steadiness in the cabinet is what's
ultimately
what's led to david frost making this
quite extraordinary decision on a
saturday night
[Music]
the latest warning to the government
from scientists bring in new
restrictions now or see hospitals
overwhelmed in the new year
british travelers entering germany will
face quarantine on arrival from monday
as the netherlands enters his own
lockdown to curb the spread of omicron
[Music]
adele and ed sheeran lead the pack as
the brit awards unveils his new look
nominations list doing away with male
and female categories
the weather a dull start for central
southern and eastern areas but some
sunny spells in scotland northern
england and west wales
and as opposed to eight we'll be taking
a look at your sunday papers for the
editor of spite tom slater and
anthropologist and broadcaster marianne
ohata
[Music]
hello good morning welcome to sky news
breakfast boris johnson's government has
been dealt another blow with the
resignation of one of his senior cabinet
ministers
well the brexit minister lord david
frost cited high taxes net zero
commitments and more recently covert
regulations as reasons he's unhappy with
the direction of government
and this comes as the prime minister
faces pressure from scientists to
introduce tougher measures to contain
the spread of the omicron variant
and after a rebellion from his own mps
against new rules
while lord frost's resignation has
caused disquiet among brexit supporting
tories particularly as negotiations with
the eu over the northern ireland
protocol reached their final stages
our political correspondent rob powell
has more
not well known publicly but lord david
frost was a crucial part of boris
johnson's government
in charge of the brexit talks he
negotiated the withdrawal agreement and
the trade deal with the eu but he's now
resigned citing unhappiness with high
taxes the focus on net zero and coveted
restrictions
in his resignation letter to the prime
minister lord frost said you know my
concerns about the current direction of
travel i hope we will move as fast as
possible to where we need to get to a
lightly regulated low tax
entrepreneurial economy while on the
covert rule changes he said you took a
brave decision in july against
considerable opposition to open up the
country again sadly it did not prove to
be irreversible
at the end of a rocky week for downing
street that seen a back bench rebellion
and by-election loss this was the last
thing the prime minister needed
this is just the latest um example of
the government just being all over the
place not just on brexit but on covid
and
i think the lack of leadership the lack
of clarity the lack of steadiness in the
cabinet is what's it ultimately
what's led to david frost making this
quite extraordinary decision on a
saturday night
lord frost's exit also throws the
ongoing brexit negotiations into
uncertainty talks are due to resume with
the eu in the new year amid briefing
that the uk could be about to alter its
position on northern ireland
what boris johnson does next matters
lord frost was seen by brexiteers as a
guardian of brexit if he's replaced by
someone who's perceived as a softer
touch then that could anger the very mps
who are already beginning to lose faith
in the prime minister
already leaked whatsapp messages show
anxiety among some conservatives with
one describing lord frost's exit as a
disaster and another saying it's a
hammer blow to the prime minister
whoever takes over now is going to have
to be just as strong and just as tough
with the european union because the
european union is not going to give in
on this unless they are really
show that the united kingdom government
means what it says
boris johnson goes into christmas week
hobbled on many fronts and faced with
tough decisions over covid regulations
for now ministers seem intent on waiting
for more data before potentially
tightening restrictions but events have
weakened the prime minister at the worst
possible moment
rob powell sky news in westminster
scientists have issued a fresh plea to
the government to bring in tougher
covert restrictions within days to stop
hospitals becoming overwhelmed
scientists on the sage advisory group
say that there are now hundreds of
thousands of daily infections
and our warning that the numbers of
hospitalizations from covet is likely to
peak in january as well as over three
thousand every day even with the current
plan b restrictions
and all this against the backdrop of
growing calls from an already
beleaguered hospitality industry for
more financial support as the sector
faces yet another christmas impacted by
the virus skies emma birchley
reports saturday night before christmas
and pubs and restaurants would usually
be packed
instead the streets of chizik were half
empty it seems the threat of omicron
prompted people to vote with their feet
but senior government scientists are
convinced the only course of action to
prevent hospitals being overrun
is to remove the choice and return to
the kind of restrictions seen during
lockdown
the number of cases we're seeing
reported are probably the people who got
infected about maybe up a couple of days
ago and these are the people
unfortunately some of them will then
start getting admitted into hospital in
in about a week's time so whatever
decision is made say today that will
start to will start to see the effect on
hospitalizations probably in about
one or two weeks time
earlier this week mps voted in plan b
enforcing mask wearing in most indoor
venues and the need for proof of
vaccination or a negative test to get
into nightclubs and large events
working from home was also advised
but now the pressure is on the
government to come up with a plan c and
fast
the scientists have warned a significant
reduction in transmission is needed to
keep hospitalizations below previous
peaks with admissions expected to hit
more than 3 000 a day in january unless
further action is taken
it's understood experts who advise the
government believe there are now
hundreds of thousands of infections each
day and once again the biggest risk
factor is deemed to be mixing with
others indoors
at the pilot pub and restaurant in
chizik the function room remained empty
all day after two events were cancelled
at the last minute
it's pretty terrifying basically
for myself all of my staff really all of
us are unsure as to what's going to
happen in the past we had the follow
scheme and at least that could guarantee
that people were receiving money
basically
if they're not willing to offer us a
thought
i'm i'm terrified basically dad okay
there was a sense of resigned
inevitability among those who'd ventured
out
we'll be in for another lockdown i
reckon we might be after christmas or
after new year it wouldn't be what i
wanted to happen but
at the same time it was the right thing
to do i think a lot of people maybe
would accept it i think if restrictions
are the way that we need to go then
that's what we have to do right
it's depressing but it's true
further restrictions would give more
time for boosters to be given
and a further 22.5 million pounds has
been allocated to target areas of low
uptake
the government says it'll keep its
measures under review based on emerging
data
but listening to the scientists it
doesn't bode well
emma birchley sky news west london
what a british medical association has
warned that almost 50 000 doctors nurses
and other nhs staff in england could be
off sick with covert 19 by christmas day
if the government does not introduce
further measures to stop the spread of
omicron let's get more on this now from
melena viscelinovic who joins me from
the newsroom melania some strong warning
there to the government and of course we
know the government appears on the face
of it anyway reluctant to introduce any
new tougher restrictions but the
question is are we delaying the
inevitable so far the government is
reluctant but these are some very
strange strong words from the bma follow
following up the sage comments that
we've had and what the bma says is that
they basically compared the current case
numbers and trends and applied that to
the workforce of the nhs in england and
came up with several scenarios and worst
of them being that there could be as
many as 130 000 nhs staff in england off
sick that's one in ten of the workforce
in england and what the bma says is that
could have horrible consequences on the
care provided to people by the health
service and not just patients who have
coveted 19 but it will also affect
urgent care and also treatments for
other patients with other serious
conditions now what the bma says we need
are further restrictions because they
say that relying the booster program
alone is not enough now in a statement
the bma's council chair dr chang nagpur
has said the westminster government's
strategy of relying solely on
vaccinations is not enough it's poor
public health practice and is already
causing preventable harm not only to the
nhs but also to education and the
economy now he went on to say if our
estimates of staff absence are realized
which we honestly hope they are not this
would be truly devastating leading to an
inability to provide even some of the
most urgent services now the bma is
calling for cancelling of large indoor
events the reintroduction of that two
meter social distancing rule that we
used to have and also crucially sending
a strong message to the public to limit
mixing right now before christmas
melania thank you
and there'll be more on the omicron
variant and the prospect of further
restrictions on trevor phillips on
sunday later this morning here on sky
news and trevor's guests today include
the health secretary sergey javid
you can watch that interview live from 8
30 and also join the conversation with
the hashtag phillips
well joining me now is dr simon clark
who's a microbiologist at the university
of redding good to have you this morning
and we're seeing for ourselves the rate
at which omicron is sweeping through the
country do you support
tougher restrictions should we see
tougher restrictions this side of
christmas
well regretfully the numbers are getting
uh very high they're they're increasing
faster than i think anybody seriously
anticipated a week or two ago
so
to keep those numbers down in
anticipation of a lot more people
turning up in hospital there there
probably do need to be
a does need to be a tightening of those
restrictions
and we're just hearing from the british
medical association which is warning
that almost 50 000 staff could be off
sick by christmas day if the government
does not introduce further measures to
stop this drop and the spread of omicron
what are you predicting looking at the
rates of the nhs at the moment well this
is another big question we focus on
hospitalizations and deaths and i think
quite rightly but the the wider effect
this has on society it won't just be the
nhs that is hit hard by
a lot of people going off sick if the
country is hit by a mass sickness event
then all of the public services
including the nhs are going to be hit by
lots of people going off sick the police
the fire councils and there's going to
be a downturn in economic activity from
that as well
so it's not just the nhs that's going to
be hit but of course that's an important
one to take into consideration
and what do you make of the data that's
coming out of south africa at the moment
which indicates that hospitals have not
been overwhelmed
well hospitals haven't been overwhelmed
but their numbers of hospitalizations
are is going up and their excess death
rate has been going up as well and we've
got to remember that you can't easily
translate one country's situation to
another the you know the results of an
infectious disease are a function of the
people it infects the bug that's doing
the infecting and the environment and
south africa has a a younger population
and they're in their spring heading into
their summer so circumstances will be
different and right throughout this
they've had a lower infection fatality
rate right from the very go so um their
situation is going to be different from
ours
and we have to wait and see
exactly what's going to happen here and
exactly how hard we're going to be hit
and the government of course had a
target for the boosters of about a
million a day but we're not hitting that
figure why do you think that is
i think the infrastructure and it's
worth pointing out we've never had a
million a day even if we had exactly the
same setup as we had
nine months ago six months ago then we
probably would be hitting a million a
day the infrastructure is simply
not there at the moment um and of course
it's worth remembering that uh if like
me you're going to get your booster
today mine's at this evening
it'll be another week before really
immunity starts to become appreciable
and uh
in that time the numbers of infections
will continue to grow
and what lessons do you think we've
learned so far looking at the trend from
last year and also looking at this year
uh that you need to act soon not later
and that's why sage that's why people
like chris whittie are
as worried as they are they would
rightly be criticized for not having
learned the lessons of the pandemic if
they just sat around and waited to see
what's going to happen before acting
so with that being said about saying you
need to act soon do you think that the
government has acted soon enough this
time round uh it seems given the advice
from sage that uh they they've acted but
perhaps not acted tough enough
dr simon clark thanks for your time this
morning you're welcome
well let's take a closer look then at
the latest covert data
and there are now almost 25 000
confirmed omicron cases in the uk that's
an increase of more than 10 000 in the
last 24 hours and that's three times as
many as the 3
201 new cases recorded on friday now
although the actual numbers are thought
to be much higher
and looking at coronavirus infections as
a whole there have been 90
418 new cases recorded in the latest
24-hour period another 125 deaths have
been reported within 28 days of a
positive test so this brings a total
number of deaths in the uk to 147
173.
now omicron is also sweeping through
europe as cases surge
germany has become the latest country to
introduce travel restrictions on the uk
from 11 pm tonight travellers will need
to see
quarantine for two weeks and have a
negative pcr result to enter the country
is after officials classified the uk as
a virus variant area of concern that's
the highest covert risk level
germany's also been reporting around 50
000 infections a day but the number has
been steadily dropping since the
beginning of december
meanwhile the netherlands has entered a
new lockdown this morning
non-essential shops restaurants and
schools will all shut until mid-january
and residents can only have two visitors
other than christmas and new year when
four will be allowed
caretaker prime minister mark rutter
said that the measures were unavoidable
because of omicron and rumors of a
lockdown led to a surge in christmas
shopping yesterday with rotterdam's
mayors saying that the cc was too busy
and urged people to stay away
so the weather then what has it got in
store for us let's take a look shall we
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
well there's a lot of rain i can tell
you that much high pressure continues to
protect us from the atlantic rain but
and there's always the bites isn't there
only for so long by the middle of the
coming week conditions will become
colder and more unsettled this will be
dull to the day to start the day for
central southern and eastern areas with
extensive missed low cloud and fog
the omicron variant is wreaking havoc
across the uk
and is threatening to throw the country
back into lockdown
just as the festive season gets underway
well joining me now is dr helen lawal
great to have you on sky news this
morning are we just delaying the
inevitable should we have a lockdown
this christmas because many people will
be mixing if not
i think what we have to remember is that
we know that vaccines are really
effective we know that they've reduced
hospitalizations and death and actually
the emphasis here is on getting boosted
now so the government are calling on a
national mission encouraging people to
step forward to have their first second
and third vaccinations so that we can
create a wall of defense agreements
against omicron which we know is highly
transmissible we know that the rates are
doubling at a rate of every two to three
days and
we know that the best protection is for
as many people to get vaccinated as
quickly as possible so it now is
becoming more urgent and more important
than ever that people step forward and
get boosted now
and what the government's struggling to
meet is ambition of one million booster
vaccines a day what do you put that down
to it's managed 800
last time
well actually we're reaching the 2600
000 i'm sorry not 800 800 000
well actually we're reaching the 26
million booster mark now so for me
that's a real positive and
part of the way that we're trying to
combat um the uptake is by launching a
street team it's an army of vaccine
ambassadors which are up and down the
country from newcastle to brighton and
they're really taking to the streets and
interacting with the public they've got
um each team has got their own vaccine
burst they're providing information and
reassurance for the public and also
there's lots and lots of extra pop-up
sites that are happening and some of
them are the vaccine centers new vaccine
centers are also open 24 hours so
we're really trying to make it as easy
as possible for people to get vaccinated
and everyone is going to be offered that
boost of vaccine over the age of 18 by
the new year
and we know that some people are still
yet to come forward for a vaccine is
there a particular group of people
um
i mean
part of the way that the street team are
working is they're they're going out and
they're speaking 33 different languages
so we're really hoping that any groups
of people that perhaps weren't getting
the information about the importance of
this before are are going to be reached
and and really because we're wanting
people to have their first second and
third booster vaccines we're really
calling on everyone even those who have
already had a vaccine to come and get
their booster
and what about age group are we seeing a
disparity between older people and
younger people when it comes to the
vaccine still
yeah and i wonder if this is partly due
to accessibility i know that now some of
the pop-up sites are appearing in more
accessible areas with higher footfall
and that we're seeing people present and
overnight in some of the 24-hour centers
coming forward for their vaccines and
and so we're really hoping that by
making it easier than ever
people are going to step forward from
across all age groups and and they can
do this by attending some of the pop-up
sites the vaccine centers booking online
at nhs dot uk forward slash covered
vaccine or calling 119. so there really
are so many ways
to get booked in now for the vaccine
and do you think we should take a
tougher approach to vaccines like
austria and italy for example and
introduce vaccine passports for example
i think at the moment we need to really
focus on getting as many people
vaccinated as possible and by getting
the message out there
um what we don't want to do is we don't
want to um
exclude people who haven't yet had their
vaccine who are keen to get it done and
maybe haven't found it convenient or
maybe haven't had the information so i
think it's really important at the
moment that the the message remains
positive and and that we know that
omicron is spreading fast and also we
know that the omicron variant um
the efficacy of the vaccine is is lower
than with the delta
and that's why people who have already
had the first and second vaccine must
step forward for the booster because we
know what the booster does is it raises
that protection up against and above 70
which is really where we want it to be
so to not become complacent even if
you've had your first and your second
and to step forward to have your booster
dr helen lawal thanks for your time this
morning thank you
well a raft of new measures to tackle
the omicron variant have now been
announced across europe in recent days
in denmark all cinemas theaters and
museums must close from today
and some of the danish queens global
jubilee celebrations which was due to
take place in january have even been
postponed well i'm now joined now to
discuss the situation in denmark is the
chairman of the covet variant assessment
committee professor trulls lillyback
thanks for your time this morning just
bring us up to date then with how the
omicron variant is acting in your
country what's the rate of infection at
the moment
we are still seeing a doppling every
second or third day in denmark so we
just the other day we we reached 10 000
cases and you have to remember we a
country of 5.8 million inhabitants and
we're also seeing an increasing number
of admissions every day
uh so so we are a bit uh worried
at the moment
and what is it that um you're doing at
the moment because you do have some
restrictions don't you just bring us up
to date with some of the latest
restrictions that you have and do you
think that you should be going far
further
yeah i think we the just the other day
we there was a lot of new restrictions
implemented that that's how many people
you gather
it's it's also that people work from
home we have this corona passport also
restaurants closing early alcohol
you have to stop serving alcohol at a
certain time of the day so there are
many new restrictions school children
are at home now until after new year's
eve
and at the same time i think most
importantly the the vaccination is
accelerated
a lot in denmark so we're giving people
the booster jab
whether it's enough i think we it takes
a while from you implement the
restrictions until you see see the
result on the curves actually so it's a
little bit too early to say at this
moment
and you talk when you touch on the
vaccination there i mean we've seen
places like austria and italy who are
taking a very tough approach to
vaccinations and they have vaccine
passports for example is that something
that you would support
i think in denmark we have a corona
passport and you can have a green corona
passport on the basis of vaccination
that would be the easiest thing because
then it stays green but you could also
get tested very frequently
or even if you you have had the
infection you will have a green passport
for a period of time but in denmark
there is a relatively big trust in
authorities and and 77 of the population
have had the have had the vaccine and
and a lot have had the booster vaccine
right now so there is like a general
trust in vaccinations in denmark and we
are using the the messenger rna vaccines
in denmark
i mean if you cast your mind back to
last year we didn't have the vaccines
and we've obviously made such a
breakthrough having this we've also got
um testing which is accelerated what
lessons do you think that you've learned
from last year
compared to this year
yeah i
i think uh well
that's difficult i think we we are going
to have a
coronavirus
around for a while and and and it was a
surprise to see a new variant with such
a enormous ability to to spread so i
think we have to to be prepared for a
long and hard wind and what we are doing
right now in denmark is trying to avoid
the blizzard and by blizzard i mean a
lot of people testing positive at the
same time because that would put an
enormous strain on the hospital system
also the staff will test positive and
have to be isolated at home or even
in extreme scenarios that have to go to
work anyway wearing mask protection
because somebody has to take care of the
the patients in the hospital so so i
think we
we need to be prepared for for a
difficult situation and of course also
planning ahead uh
the good thing is i we are seeing new
treatments that are promising the
vaccines can be changed quite fast and
we also
hope that this new omicron variant is
not giving as severe disease but it's
too early to say nevertheless if we get
a lot of cases at the same time it will
be a problem anyway
professor charles lyndabad great to have
you company thank you you're welcome
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather
sponsored by qatar airways
high pressure continues to protect us
from the atlantic rain but not for very
long by the middle of the week the
coming week conditions will become
colder and more unsettled it will be a
dull start to the day for central
southern and eastern areas with
extensive missed low cloud and fog
scotland northern england and west wells
will have a brightest start after early
fog clears
or with us this morning to review the
papers are the anthropologist and
broadcaster marianne oharta and the
editor of spiked tom slater good morning
to you both let's just dive straight
into it then shall we marianne just
looking at the front page of the
observer shows the situation that the
government is in being pulled in all
directions because on one hand
scientists are saying you have to bring
in more restrictions on the other hand
his own government rebelling against
plan b as we saw but there is a call to
have tougher restrictions isn't there
yes that's right so this is uh the
information from the um briefing that
sage the scientific advisory group for
emergencies the group of scientists who
are advising the government ministers
about how to tackle covid and omicron
wave of cases um
that's that's come out into the public
and they said they've basically said the
models suggest that there could be up to
two million new infections every day um
the models from kind of best case to
worst-case scenarios and bear in mind
these models not predictions
um could be between 600 and 6000 deaths
a day caused by both the delta variant
which is still epidemic proportions uh
levels of infection within the uk but
also of course omicron on top of that
and
one
one consideration is of course um
that number of sick people
can't be looked after by the nhs uh our
health and care system will be under
crippling pressure
and not cope but the the other side of
that is that if we allow infection uh
levels to transmission between people in
the community to be that
high
then you end up the the kind of the
country grinds to a halt because you
don't have people who you don't have
enough people who aren't infected to be
able to keep those key systems running
um the postal services
pharmacies um people delivering
groceries opening shops all that kind of
stuff you know that is important people
are going to look after um the sick the
vulnerable the elderly all those folk
who need help
just to be okay each day
so the question is
if we listen to that very vocal but um
some people have described as ignorant
group of politicians who are kind of
perhaps uh sounding off for political
gain rather than for public benefit
and saying we don't want this we don't
want curbs to our freedoms we don't want
to let omicron have um
to win we want to maintain our freedom
the question is well what are you giving
freedom to then you're giving freedom to
omicron to effectively destroy the
country destroy our health and care
system
um
learning to live with this virus doesn't
mean ignoring it and carrying on
regardless it means learning to adapt
and live with it in that respect we
can't pretend it's not there we can't
pretend it doesn't have an impact and so
the question is do you want to listen to
politicians who are yes democratically
elected but not scientific experts or do
we want to listen to the scientists well
there's one thing that the scientists
are definitely pushing for and also
government which is the booster so at
least on you know on on one page there
and we'll stay with the observer tom
because this is about the booster
walking sensors not enough to deliver uh
the boosters
yes so in this report and the observer
points out that large sways of the
country including some major cities um
have no walking centers whatsoever so
places like norwich peterborough and
york are mentioned here which is a
particular problem not just at the time
in which you're trying to roll out
boosters nationwide but also in terms of
particular hard-to-reach pockets of the
population
immigrant undocumented workers people of
this nature who won't necessarily have
contact with the gp i think i mean this
is obviously a tragedy because of how
effective these boosters are these
really are long-term our way out of the
pandemic the rollout was already pushing
down very significantly on
hospitalizations and deaths at the point
in which even before omicron came along
and this is something which the
government certainly has to look at i
mean if i might just come back a little
bit on what marianne said there very
quickly i think one thing that's worth
bearing in mind is the key word here in
relation to what's coming out of station
the rest of it is models and scenarios
right if you go on the spectators data
hub who've been tracking all this
throughout the past few months they have
a dreadful track record in terms of
predicting what's going to happen with
hospitalizations and deaths because
they're trying to predict the future
this isn't about data in the here and
now and they present often worst-case
scenarios that's something which has
come out quite clearly neil ferguson was
predicting a hundred thousand cases a
day in the wake of the summer reopening
we never got anywhere close
to that and whilst we could dismiss this
idea of civil liberties as if it's
unimportant it is fundamentally
important especially given the fact that
we do have to learn to live with kobe we
are going to have new variants if even
in the situation where we have a lot of
immunity in the population that we still
have to lock down just in an abundance
of caution this will literally never end
and i think that's just important to
grasp as we go into this quite bleak
period it feels like absolutely so much
to juggle isn't there
with this you know as you mentioned the
civil liberties health of the nation the
nhs the economy as well um let's just
step away from covid and let's move on
to other stories because the front page
of the sun marianne it's um you know it
shows some you know concerns that the
queen
has at first glance i thought she just
didn't want william to be using the
helicopter just you know but actually
there's a serious reason behind that
isn't there why she doesn't want him to
be using the helicopter
yeah so this is the news like you say as
a a kind of slightly grim palette
cleanser from from all the chat about
covid um the queen has apparently raised
concerns with prince william about him
traveling with his whole family so kate
and the three children um in helicopters
because
i mean i've never been in a helicopter i
know i have that that's a lie and most
of us don't travel every day in
helicopters um
but you know we all kind of know that as
a track record when something goes wrong
in a helicopter it goes catastrophically
wrong and so the concern is that if
there were to be um a a a crash
then the
not only would the queen lose her her
grandson and and three of her her
great-grandchildren
also the succession to the throne would
be um
thrown into disarray because if you've
you've got prince charles but then
you've got william and george and
charlotte and louie and if they all die
it's horrible to talk about but if they
all were to die then it the next um
person in in the royal succession would
be prince harry in principle except he's
resigned from being a royal um and
harry's children um liliber and
what's his name archie um so at that
point it's the duke of york who is not
anyone's favorite royal by a long
stretch of the imagination
concerned about um you know looking
after the safety of her family it's also
what would happen to the royal family if
something were to go very badly wrong
absolutely my goodness and when you
mentioned that helicopter disasters i
thought of kobe bryant who of course um
had you know died in that in that
circumstance absolutely horrific this is
something that touchwood we hope doesn't
happen that everybody stays safe of
course um let me come to you tom because
this is a story that many people will be
waking up to lord frost resigning
yes so a huge bomb show overnight it was
the mail on sunday's scoop actually came
out last night that lord frost the
brexit minister um is resigning he had
actually attended his resignation
earlier but the
number 10 had basically talked him into
staying on until january because given
all of the scandals enveloping this
government they didn't think they could
take a high profile resignation this um
scoop has effectively forced his hand
he's issued his resignation letter
it points towards disagreements with the
government on various different elements
of policy
particularly covered policy vaccine
passport seems to be a key thing uh tac
tax hikes being another thing that seems
to have upset lord frost the story in
the background which isn't really being
touched upon is the fact that whilst
we've all been focusing on code it's
become pretty clear that the government
appears to be about to um backtrack and
capitulate in the negotiations with the
eu over northern ireland on the question
of the european court of justice which
is a very big red line for lord frost i
think it just adds to this sense that
this prime minister is very much in
battles has um fewer defenders than he
ever has done and that general sense
that um whilst the pandemic would have
blown any government of course to put it
lightly it seems to have blown any sense
of principle or substance out of this
one you've seen one u-turn after another
on all kinds of different elements and
some of the people who were very key to
this johnson administration have clearly
had enough as we've seen with this
absolutely it's just another blow isn't
it for boris johnson's government north
forkshire obviously thrown into the
mixed party scandal also thrown into the
mix so there's a lot for him to worry
about and a baby possibly crying
throughout the night as well as if he
hasn't got enough on his plate marianna
hotter and tom slater great to have you
with us this morning thank you so much
for your company
and of course we'll be back after this
short break
[Music]